I think John would have been very
pleased to see his name attached to this
prize he was fearless he was courageous
he was an excellent science journalist
he was willing to expose and entertain
maverick ideas as long as they stood up
to the tests of the rigors of scientific
evidence I think in my late husband I
had unusual combination of supreme
knowledge of science and eloquence and
and clarity and expression and he had
been on the garden had been an academic
and then he got a job in The Guardian
and realized it was more fun than
anything he'd ever thought of and I
think he's always a supreme example of
science journalism and I think other
people that will do well to try to live
up to his ideal for nature the Maddox
prize means something that we try to do
that is stand up for scientific values
be independently minded in our criticism
of people outside science when they
abuse science and people inside science
when they abuse a scientific process for
their own ends what we were looking for
was people who had really gone but above
and beyond their role their job and what
we would expect of them and to take
responsibility for an area of public
discussion pursuing a cause dogged Lee
investigating the arguments presenting
them well to the public the quality of
communication was very important because
that was close to John Maddox ism own
heart the judging was really challenging
we had to look at really quite diverse
situations and things that people were
dealing with people dealing with things
in countries like China and trying to
publish around issues which were
contentious they're quite different
often from the sort of environment
perhaps we see in the UK and in the US
one of the difficulties was the
embarrassment of riches that we had with
the
wrath of nominations and also a broad
set of criteria for this award we found
considerable difficulty deciding what
kind of person we might give the prize
to should it be a campaigning journalist
defending the principles of science over
a wide area should it be an active
researcher finding themselves in a
controversial topic and deciding to
pursue it rather than simply moving
safely onto something else I think the
degree of courage involved in the face
of really acute hostility made the
particular people we had stand out and
then we finally agreed as it can happen
in judging you suddenly I think we were
going to fight about all this and then
suddenly consensus emerges and then we
realized who was the best choice so we
went for that so the first person I
month announced can't be with us tonight
his name is Fang Shih min he's a Chinese
science writer he was trained as a
biochemist he runs a website in Chinese
which in English translation is called
new threads and what he absolutely
thrives on but will prob of courage to
do so I say he's right he's got a huge
amount of recognition within China for
this activity is exposing scientific
fraud amongst the epidemic Museum bad
bogus medicine lanoxin medical
so it covers the whole territory in that
sense of what the Maddox cries is about
so he's not here but I believe we have a
little video from him as well and then
somebody here will come take the prize
in his I'm truly honored to receive Jan
Methos class Sam's in China faces great
challenges from g-voice diction
pseudoscience and high science and
scientific misconduct there are more and
more Chinese people realized vicious a
big problem and are standing up for
science I consider this war was an
acknowledgement of our efforts from
international science community and I
deeply appreciate it thank you the other
prizes here is final Wesley
Simon Simon is a psychiatrist many of
you will know but it's worth just
recording that his efforts have been
especially above all devoted to looking
into chronic fatigue syndrome and also
into me the problem you like beset by
military personnel and veterans he has
suffered acute hostility I think he's
the first had him talk to him about this
he's the first to acknowledge that there
are other people in his disciplines we
also suffered an acute hostility however
I think partly because of the very
public role in the midst of that
hostility that he would be willing to
adopt I think that singles him out
accounts for his nomination so it's okay
so it's a very great pleasure to
acknowledge simon as a very worthy
winner for this price Simon do come
forward
well thank you very much fantastic
honour the delight and in particular
because I did read the rubric for the
prize yesterday if you notice that it
did say it's mainly for young scientists
it's not about me it is about this a
very large number of people who've been
doing the same kind of research that I
have you've had the same kind of
intimidation and harassment over the
years any one of whom could be here and
I think for all that very large group of
scientists clinicians academics this is
very much about recognizing what they've
done and how we have advanced the field
for the benefit of patients at a cost
that's true but it's very nice that
people actually do recognize that it was
worthwhile
you